-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing well
tonight.
And now we are gonna get
to the news.
Supreme Court Justice
Stephen Breyer
is reportedly planning to retire
at the end of the current term,
which would allow President
Biden to appoint a successor.
Said Mitch McConnell,
"With only three years
left in his term?
I don't think so."
President Biden visited
an ice cream store yesterday
in Washington, D.C.,
and reportedly
got a scoop of chocolate
with peanut butter flecks
and a scoop of
blackout chocolate cake.
So, yeah, he has seen
the approval numbers.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, I'm going to need
a second scoop."
President Biden met today
with the CEOs of Ford,
General Motors, and several
other companies
to discuss
his Build Back Better agenda.
But of course it
quickly devolved
into Biden pitching car names.
"What about the Ford Shark?
That's a pretty good name.
The Ford Shark."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
told reporters yesterday
that a potential
Russian invasion of Ukraine
would likely be the "largest
invasion since World War II."
So, I guess he's never been
to a Target on Black Friday.
[ Laughter ]
In a video posted on social
media today,
former President Trump told
a golfing partner
that he would be
the 45th and 47th
President of the United States.
Then again, it wouldn't be
the first time
he lied to a golf partner.
"Put me down for a 4.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's a 4.
It's a 4."
[ Applause ]
After Vermont Senator
Bernie Sanders suggested
that he would support
a primary challenger
against Democratic Senator
Joe Manchin,
Manchin said yesterday, "Senator
Sanders is not a Democrat.
Said Sanders, "Thank you."
[ Laughter ]
Organizers of next month's
Winter Olympics in Beijing
announced they will provide
free condoms to athletes.
And I'm pretty excited
to find out what that event is.
[ Laughter ]
Seems weird it's in the winter.
Amazon endorsed a bill
in Congress yesterday
that would legalize marijuana
on a federal level.
Oh, really?
Does Amazon support something
that would make it even harder
for people to go out to a store?
"Alexa, order Doritos.
Yes, make weekly."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, musician Kid Rock
released a song this week
that criticizes
coronavirus restrictions.
Oh, buddy, that's not why people
are staying six feet
away from you.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.